by the way this isn't a thing in England
and I don't care what anyone says
England is just way more low-key than it
is in America I'm hearing like women are
getting flown out here and they're flown
out there so I've never done that none
of my girlfriends from home have ever
done that it's all very bizarre to me um
the reason it's bizarre to me because
it's like why would you want to fly
somewhere and like put up with someone
like I wouldn't want to be in a foreign
country with someone that I don't know
that well I don't feel safe I don't I
don't like that like maybe he expects
from you like it's all just too much but
you just rather stay home with your
parents at this point